Waterston wasn't entirely mercenary and
when he died in the 1820s he bequeathed
that's left in his will
samples of his metals platinum and
palladium to the Royal Society and we
still have them let's see what's in the
box and here you can see there is sample
that is labeled palladium and if we look
inside
imagine that you've discovered a new
element what would you do palladium was
discovered by the chemist Wollaston and
this is what he did as shown by this
piece of paper he made palladium and
started selling it you can see here it
says palladium the new silver then down
here he has the price you can buy five
shillings half a Guinea which is ten and
a half shillings or a Guinea which is
twenty-one shillings and here he gives
some of the chemical properties to
condition that what it will dissolve in
and so on so he starts at selling it not
himself he gets Mr Forster to sell it on
his behalf and Forster claims he's the
only person that will sell it these were
discovered by Williston whose job was to
refine metals and he discovered a new
metal and if it's your business what you
do you sell it makes sense
then underneath we got a letter and the
letter was written a year later this was
1802 this is 1803 and from somedy called
chevenix who's furious he thinks it's a
fraud he doesn't think it's a new metal
and he is describing chemical tests that
he's done which shows that palladium is
not a new metal now the problem is that
Wollaston had not published a paper
describing it
so Williston got his act together and a
couple of years later he wrote a paper
and here we've got his original paper on
the discovery of palladium so he is now
describing properly for the scientific
literature what is discovered and I'm
always fascinated why people choose the
names for particular elements and here
in these papers they actually explain
why they chose the names in modern
papers
when they discover elements they
published the paper and then months
perhaps years later they actually choose
the name but here he says I subsequently
that means afterwards obtained another
metal to which I gave the name of
palladium from the planet that had been
discovered nearly at the same time there
isn't a planet as we now know with a
name that sounds like palladium but it
turns out that in 1802 they discovered a
very big asteroid which in those days
they thought was a planet and it was
called Pallas this was really
fashionable and trendy
discover an element let's name it after
the new planet and it's much the same as
people do now when they discover
something new they give it a name that
goes with the exciting things in the
time probably everybody was really
excited about a new planet and this was
just cashing in on that especially if
you're trying to sell things but what
this paper does is to show that the
element was real and he describes some
of the reactions and he made this
element by dissolving up and aw that's a
rock that was containing minerals of
various noble metals platinum and so on
and by careful precipitation he could
precipitate one metal after another in
here got a box and inside the two lumps
of metal we come back to these in a
minute and here you can see there is
sample that is labeled palladium there
are there is a two pieces of palladium
and somebody has written something on
this one but what's interesting he left
these samples the Royal Society to be
used for science so you can see
somebody's chopped off one of these
corners must have done an experiment
with it and this piece looks a very
strange shape so lots of bits have
probably been trimmed
fit and then in here there is a
inscription saying the Palladium in this
packet has been rolled from fused
buttons what that means is they made
round pieces and then put it through
rollers so out came a continuous sheet
and you can see here well let's see
what's inside I haven't seen it myself
there are two more pieces this one is a
bit strange somebody's tried to get a
splinter off it there is some writing on
it
this one says number six and somebody
else has written something else on it
now what's really exciting about these
samples is the letter they're all the
list that I've got here and this list is
signed if you look down here by Michael
Faraday one of the really great chemists
and physicists who's ever lived it's a
list of all the pieces of platinum and
palladium that he could find in the
collection of the Royal Society what is
written at the beginning is or somebody
else has written way to palladium 74
ounces weight of platinum
that means platinum 45 ounces and a bit
and Faraday is written out underneath I
find only 28 ounces 420 grains of
platinum and 73 ounces and 373 grains of
palladium at this date the 11th of
February 1834 so Michael Faraday is sort
of saying some of these pinched some of
the platinum nearly half in the same box
as you saw there are two pieces here
which are of a very dense metal they
feel very heavy which i think might be
the platinum
but they're not labeled they didn't have
any paper around them just a piece of
plastic so I think we're going to have
to get somebody to do a chemical test to
tell us if these really are platinum or
palladium and what is really important
that these are the samples that Michael
Faraday used to do all his
electrochemical experiments and so it's
really like being back in his lab